gonna be right-hander michael walka
making his ninth traditional start of
the season 13th overall game
one and two on the record era of 5.19
came off of the il on may the 23rd and
since then he was really been limited
however his last time out he was able to
get to three and two thirds as far as
the innings go up to 77 pitches so you
assume tonight he's going to be capable
of going north of that and hopefully
giving the raise a good solid five
innings at least
and uh cutting the miss
he struck him out and he
changed speeds with him he did he got
him into swing mode on that fastball and
finally got chavis to to bite on the
change up and this wasn't even a better
one here by waka that ball bounces in
front of the plate but he still gets the
big swing down to one knee as a matter
of fact 286 nine home runs for alex and
he'll take ball four something that alex
cora has been trying to get his ball
club to do more frequently so a man on
in front of martinez and they're cutting
the mouse
is out on strikes tell you what that
right there is the pitch of the night so
far by waka you talk about selling and
change up
keeping it in the zone for a long time
over the heart of the plate you force
the swing hey nick pavetta looking to
turn it around right now six and three
or four thirty six a little funk
recently with a long ball last time out
pitch a decent game one bad pitch
three-run bomb and a 2-2 on the way
swinging in a miss to strike him out
with the heater so lao fans and now
wonder funko rookie phenom 20 years
young two for seven including a home run
here in the first game of the series and
his debut and three rbis and an o2 pitch
here it is 97 to blow him away back to
back hayes for pavetta boy looks like
nolan ryan the first two hitters nothing
but cash yeah and they they want to
throw him fast balls and they want to
throw him fastball's left-handed above
the belt now that fastball plays that's
playing big time first two hitters and
his 3-2
is a curve swung on and missed strike
three strikes out the side gotta love
that pace and the production
now the one-two from waka
swinging at a fly ball in the shallow
right center kier meyer drifting over to
his left is there to make the catch and
it's another nice one two three inning
it for michael walker i'll tell you both
these pitchers have gone right to work
tonight
good oh filthy
tough guy to whiff got him so he strike
out four out of the first seven one gone
once again that good breaking ball the
good curveball this one down in the dirt
and it's two in one kier meyer 224 with
a homer and 10 driven and his offensive
production has really suffered this year
here's the 2-1 swinging a high fly into
left center field
coming together verdugo and hernandez
and alex in left field is there inning
over
perfect through three for the intense
nick pavetta yelling to himself let's go
boys come on
guards came into this game two of five
in his career against waka
skies it to the right side lao angling
out from second
and he will make the call moreno right
there behind him
two up two
or field denver's on his way to the
plate
popped up
this is franco after it he's got it to
retire the side one two three go to red
sox once again as waka got into the
kitchen of a few red sox hitters this
inning about this he's
quickly behind in the count that's news
with the way he has come out throwing
the ball tonight
and a lead-off walk
for the rays got their first base runner
a four pitch walk drum by brandon lau
one two fastball called strike three
perfect pitch for pavetta top of the
zone outside corner and there's one away
runner on the move is swinging at a high
pop-up
[Applause]
renfro will make the catch and getting
back in
will be loud i thought for a moment
maybe lau had forgotten how many outs
there were
he's out
he's out he didn't touch second base wow
how about that he went down to the bag
and did not retouch
on his way back to first so he has been
doubled up so the ray's looked at the
video and they say that they caught him
struck out his first time up
how about this swing little looper into
left it's gonna drop down for a base hit
sliding stop by meadows but how about
that swing
for the first hit a little hand grenade
he threw out there is what he did
one hopper short grabbed by franco throw
it's high but right down on the bag
comes diaz at a fine play
by the youngster wander franco out at
shortstop there
to get [ __ ] hernandez yes siree 2-2
he got struck him out and even with the
daring exploits of christian vasquez
waka bears down to get the hitter and
stops the red sox in their tracks one
down one on the 3-1
swing and he ropes that one into right
field on the move renfro oh play
and up into the wall he'll fire back to
the infield man what a catch by hunter
renfron circus catch by renfro
spectacular play by ran for really one
of his better catches and he's made some
really good ones he had to leap behind
him he kind of went on a straight line
route he recovered once the ball was
kind of over his head both of these
teams want this series he has the runner
with first he's ready to roll vetted to
the set
the payoff pitch swing and a miss at a
high slider then he goes
punch on number six no hits off pavetta
for five innings
right now it's debra's rasmussen
battling it out
again the two ball two strike pitch
and a one hopper grab by lyle
throw to first got him
that fastball endeavors is out for three
the red sox lead two so now a base
runner with two down for the kid juan de
franco no balls two strikes this will be
the 85th pitch of the game for nick
pavetta now the pitch is swung on and
missed he struck him out beautiful
curveball and the first real sign of
frustration from the young kid franco he
slams his bat down in disgust the hitter
is going to be
christian vasquez
and the soft lighter going to be over
the head
of franco
kirmire with the pickup there's going to
be a play at the plate and the runner is
out
renfro trying to score
kirbyer came in
made the pickup with the idea of coming
to the plate and boy does he gunned down
rimfrom red sox nothing and tampa bay
nothing three men have gotten on base
two on walks one a hit batsman that's
all against him
ground ball right along the line knocked
down by chavis throw to first base and
will not get him so chavis will be
charged with an error oh and two here it
is swinging a ground ball up the middle
it could be two bogarts no the runner
was off with the pitch throw to first in
time to get diaz had meadows not been
running i think that was a taylor made
double play question about it and the
hook is out he's smiling as pavetta he
comes out without having allowed a hit
no hitter for six and two thirds
and popped up here into left charging on
it verdugo and makes the play
to retire the side two men stranded
still nothing nothing tampa bay has been
no hit through seven innings six and two
thirds no it innings by pavetta
and there's a big set the other way
kiermeier will make the turn at first
he's going to dig for two and he is safe
at second base
kiermeier takes it the other way
and the raids with their first hit have
a man in scoring position two on the
count
winner takes off from first
and no throw on a swing and miss
so franco will pick up a stolen base his
first in the big leagues uncontested one
two coming
swung on and popped it up
vazquez looking for room here comes
debra's vasquez makes the plan he
stumbles over the chair he caught it
he's gone pitches down and the throw is
not in time
into center field he's headed to third
and the throw there will not be in time
looks demarco at third in pitches we're
gonna miss the ball gets away heading
home mardel here's to throw the tag
ray's win
marco scores the raise win one nothing
and they're back in first place in the
american ladies